in the potential divorce case of Tom  Brady and his wife Gisele Bundchen was  recently spotted visiting a holistic  healer and burning sage as the rumors of  her impending divorce persist so I  looked up the holistic healer and Sage  burner and this is what it says on this  lady's website I offer a natural and  holistic approach to medicine I'm an  ayurvedic traditional medicine doctor  based in the Boca Raton area not  Varanasi India not some Guru Baba in  India in Boca Raton right outside of  Palm Beach okay and I believe in the  power of healing through natural and  healthy alternatives man or compliments  to Western medicine you know I'm an  educator and a Healer with the mission  to teach each patient about the natural  healing powers they hold within so I I'm  not being hyperbolic at all when I say  this she's a witch she's just this is  what witchcraft is